foreign
[Music]
ER and I am a computer scientist at nist
I work on the human genomics team
so before I get started with my
presentation I'd like to thank the
organizers for the opportunity to
present this talk
today I'll be presenting work in the
genome in a bottle Consortium
that is developing working to develop a
comprehensive variation Benchmark for
medically relevant genes on chromosome
1-22
so a little background on the geometa
bottle project and the benchmarks that
are generated by it so nist co-leads
Consortium
and genome in a bottle Consortium
develops Metrology infrastructure for
the characterization of whole Human
Genome variant detection
so the way nist has accomplished this is
that it helps develop seven broadly
consented Human Genome cell lines
including two mother father-son trios
shown on the right hand side of this
figure
and so from one large group of each of
these cell lines the DNA was extracted
and the extracted DNA was actually
turned into what's known as a nist
reference material
so reference materials
include reference values and so the
reference values for each one of these
reference materials are the
whole human genome
germline variants that are detected and
can be used to Benchmark sequencing
Technologies and variant calling methods
so the evolution of the geomena bottle
benchmarks so this project started about
2012 and so the first two years of the
project there was focus on the pilot
genome anyone
na12878 or in a geomet bottle labeling
hgo1
so the works develop a small variant
Benchmark
on grch37 and this covered about 77
percent of the reference and so this
allowed methods developers and
sequencing technology developers to
character to characterize how well their
variant calling methods and variant
detection was performing on a specific
reference material
so from 2015 to 2019 there was work
expanding the number of samples in the
genome bottle collection to include
members of different ancestries and then
also focus on developing Trio samples so
mother father son
so during this time the genomata bottle
Consortium published a small variant
Benchmark that covered between 80 and 90
percent of grch37 and grch38 for these
seven samples
and then also for better use of The
Benchmark variant columns
genome in the bottle worked with the
Global Alliance for genomics and health
to develop a set of best practices for
comparing a variant call set to the
genome metabolic benchmarks to identify
performance
so recently a genomic model has also
published structural variant benchmarks
and also a phase deployed assembly of
the major histocompatibility complex of
hgo2
and also developed with long read and
linked read technology a new version of
the small variant Benchmark that covers
more challenging regions of the genome
and covers between 92 percent and 94
depending on grch38 or grch37 of the
human genome on chromosomes 1 through
22.
so I'm just going to briefly walk
through our recommendations for how to
use the geometa bottle benchmarks
so the benchmarks the small variant and
structural variant VCF and bed files
containing regions of the genome that
include those variants
are available on the FTP at the bottom
right hand corner of this slide hosted
by collaborators at the ncbi
so that FTP also includes Beyond just
the released VCF and bed files that are
used as benchmarks it also includes
sequencing data that's publicly
available for each one of the cell lines
a short B and long read sequencing as
well as different analysis that has been
done by the genome in a bottle
Consortium so different variant call
sets and then draft benchmarks
so the releases folder that I denote at
the bottom of this slide
so that contains the VCF and Benchmark
beds that have been evaluated against a
variety of call sets and so the resource
development process that we go through
is detailed in manuscripts and then also
preprints from genome in a bottle
another important item for identifying
performance of variant calling methods
is stratification of the human genome
and there are stratification files that
have been generated by genome in a
bottle that are available on the FTP in
an example use case in a recent
Precision FDA challenge in which we
released the version 4 Benchmark and
sequencing data for the hgo2 sample and
then release just sequencing data for
the parents of hgo2
then people would submit the variant
calls on HG 3 and 4 and we compared them
to benchmarks that we had generated
and so a manuscript of describing both
the stratifications and then also the
performance of those different type of
different methods is at the link
provided
so on the right hand side there's a
figure from the best practices
benchmarking paper so what any user we
expect to have is a VCF from that
contains the variance from any of the
geomet cell lines
so the
what we provide is both overall
Visa truth VCF and then also a bed file
that contains those uh those very the
regions that contain those varying calls
then also we make available the
stratification beds we recommend using a
tool like app.py that both wraps
comparison tools we commonly use the
comparison tool VCF eval to compare to
vcfs
and then quantify the performance in the
different uh confident regions and
stratifications using hap.py and then a
report detailing performance uh across
the different regions of the genome
between the given query VCF and the
grand truth data set is provided for
users to understand how well how well
their variant calling method is
performing
so in terms of new benchmarks we
recently generated a version 4 small
variant Benchmark and so this used Pac
bio Hi-Fi long reads and then 10x
freedomic linked reads
so this was an improvement over the
previous version the version 3 of The
Benchmark
in terms of coverage of the non-gaap
reference genome
and then also we included The Benchmark
that was generated using the phase
diploid assembly of the pack bio Hi-Fi
long reads of the MHC and so you can see
that the coverage has increased for
version four compared to the previous
Benchmark version
and then also the coverage of low map
ability regions and segmented
duplications has increased substantially
compared to version three so version
three was largely based on short beads
and then version four included the short
read call sets as well as the pack bio
Hi-Fi long reads and 10x genomic linked
reads so this gave access to more
difficult regions of the genome
and so overall you can see for grch37
and grch38 from the table below uh
version 4 added about 400 000 single
nucleotide variants and indels less than
50 base pairs to The Benchmark data sets
so looking at Medical Gene coverage of
version four we have a figure from the
manuscript on the right so we wanted to
take a look at how well version 4 with
the long reads and linked reads or
covering what were known as medical
genes that were difficult to
characterize with short reads so the
criteria for that was that the mandecler
at all in 2016 they created a list of
medical genes that had at least one Exon
which was difficult to map with short
reads
so for the version 4 manuscript we
looked at how well we were covering
these uh genes
so comp this this figure uh shows that
compared to version three there's a
market increase in coverage of these
genes uh ultimately we don't cover all
medical genes that were difficult to map
with at least one short read
so the project I'm going to describe
today
goes through trying to
generate a genome in a model Benchmark
for as many medical genes as possible so
including the the criteria that was
given from mandecler at all of at least
one Exon being difficult to map with
short reads we also wanted to look at
how well we're doing across all medical
genes for us or a set of medical genes
that we could find in literature
so overall looking at how well version 4
on grch38 covered a set of medically
Gene medical development genes that we
found on chromosome 1-22 we we
discovered that there's 354 that were
less than 90 covered and so the reasons
included there were structural variate
structural variants that we exclude from
The Benchmark there were large segment
of duplications where it was difficult
to characterize and then also other
difficult regions that even a
mapping-based approach with the long
reads was weren't able to resolve so in
this project we looked at
using a diploid assembly
so there was
um human pan genome pangenom reference
Consortium in the spring of 2020 put on
a bake off of different diploid assembly
methods for the hgo2 sample and we use
the best performing deployed assembly to
help us generate a phase small variant
and structural variant Benchmark of as
many of these medical genes as possible
that weren't fully covered in version
four so we ended up generating a
benchmark for 273 medical genes and
that's what I'll be detailing today
so this figure gives the overall view of
how we generated a medical Gene
Benchmark so I'll go on the next set of
slides in depth to several of these
processes but for the high level view we
started off with finding a set of
medical genes
so then we used a trio-based diploid
assembly from a tool known HiFi Asm
and we looked at how well it resolved
each one of these medical genes compared
to the version 4 Benchmark
and then we went through a process of
manual curation and comparing to
different bearing callings
call sets
to generate a benchmark and then we have
gone through the Benchmark evaluation
with the community and we're getting
ready to release this Benchmark for use
so first looking at the medical list of
genes
the first large set of genes that we
worked with was from the mandectler at
all paper in addition to the focused uh
set that were at least one Exon were
difficult to map by short reads they
also just gathered a list of all medical
genes at the time so this was a snapshot
of omium htmd and clinvar and the
snapshots were taken between 2012 and
2015 and so this resulted in for
4773 genes
we also took a look at a product from
the cosmic
and this was the cancer Gene census and
that included
723 genes
then finally we looked at a set of genes
that are highly a commonly sequenced by
clinical labs so this was a collection
of a union of the quinjen definitive
strong and moderate evidence genes acmg
secondary findings to 2.0 list as well
as other carrier screening and commonly
tested in clinical lab Gene
Gene lists
so the figure on the right just details
the intersection of these different Gene
lists
so the diploid assembly that we use to
generate this Benchmark was a fat bio
Hi-Fi font reads
so the method to develop the assembly
was the Hi-Fi ISM and we used the the
trio information was used so this meant
that the Illumina reads for the parents
and then the pack bio Hi-Fi reads for
the son of the AJ Trio were used to
generate the assembly
so this was the best performer in the
human pan genome reference Consortium
deployed assembly Bake Off in Spring of
2020.
so the figure on the right is from the
hype ISM paper so at uh so the the Hi-Fi
reads are uh
error corrected and assembled and so
this this results in two
haplotypes and then we took the
haplotype assemblies we aligned them
back to each one of the references so
grch37 and grch38 and then we called
variance with a tool known as dip call
so this outputs variant calls as well as
confident regions and so the confident
regions for dip call is that each one of
the locations is covered by exactly one
contig from each haplotype so
so we use the difficult confident
regions to
examine genes that were less than 90
covered from the version 4 Benchmark and
we added a criteria for the difficult
confident region coverage of each gene
which included flanking sequence that
was equal to the PAC bio high five long
read length as well as being able to
fully resolve any overlapping segment
multiplications of the gene
so this resulted in 273 genes that we
then curated each gene for the accuracy
of resolving the assembly in igv
and after we had this strapped set of
genes and The Benchmark variants for
them we then requested call sets from
the community
we compared call sets to these draft
benchmarks and we manually curated a
subset of false positive and false
negatives from each subs from each call
set and so the call sets are listed
below those include Pac bio and Illumina
based call sets as well as OT and called
with a variety of different calling
methods for both small variants and
structural variants
so looking at overall statistics of the
medical Gene Benchmark Within These 273
genes so compared to the version 4
Benchmark it includes more bases more
smvs more indels and then importantly it
includes more coverage of the low map
ability and segmented applications
Within These Gene regions
so there's also a SV Benchmark that
we've generated and so that included 217
large insertions and dilutions
to test the utility of this Benchmark we
compared an Illumina novaseq jtk4 call
set against the version 4 Benchmark in
these genes and also this medically
revelant Gene Benchmark so overall the
medical Gene benchmarks detects more
errors in segmented implications and
tandem repeats and then also fewer
variants are excluded by the new
Benchmark as compared to the previous
version for Benchmark Within These genes
so highlighting a few genes in the new
Benchmark include
ncf1
which is within a challenging segment of
the vacation and the gene is seen in a
subset of patients for a primary immune
efficiency disease
so this provides us
this assembly-based approach provides us
an improvement over the alignment-based
methods that we have used historically
in genome in a model
there's also another Gene which is shown
at the right which is CBS which is
involved in homocystoprenia
and so CBS is interesting because so the
um the medical Gene Benchmark properly
resolves this Gene looking closer at
this
what the issue is with mapping based
approaches is that in the grch38
reference that there's an extra copy of
this Gene as well as a set of genes on a
chromosome 21. there'll be a Blog from
the GM records Consortium detailing how
to handle this approach as this is how
to handle
addressing this issue in grch38 and this
has been raised by the community
and then also we the deployed assembly
properties dissolves the chain smn1 so
smn1 and smn2 reside on chromosome 5 in
a large segment of duplication
it has historically been difficult to
sequence
and smn1 is involved with SMA
and so with the diploid assembly we were
able to resolve both haplotypes
of smn1 for the hgo2 sample
and so this new Benchmark allows for
characterizing performance in this
challenging region
so we don't cover smn2 yet but we will
be looking at Future deployed assemblies
to identify if this Gene is smn2 and
smn1 are both properly covered and we
can generate a benchmark for that
so the overall conclusions I want to
lead you with
are that version 4 small variant
Benchmark from genome on a model used
long and Link reads to enable
benchmarking in more segment
notifications and no mappability regions
so this improved overall coverage of the
genome there were still medically
relevant genes that were not in the
version 4 Benchmark were not fully
covered by version 4. so we wanted to
explore ways to expand our coverage for
Clinical Laboratory stakeholders so we
looked at using an assembly-based
approach for developing a benchmark to
do so we use the trio HiFi Asm
and this allowed us to Benchmark in
these more challenging medical genes
and this allowed us also to do methods
development to generate future venture
so the overall result is that we have a
phased small variant and structural
variant VCF embed that will be placed on
the genome metapodel FTP that can be
used for benchmarking these medical
genes in the hgo2 sample
future work that we are undertaking in
genome in a bottle is to produce a
chromosome X Benchmark because many of
these medical genes are also are on the
chromosome X
as well as a whole genome deployed
assembly based benchmark
so I'd like to thank all the genome at a
bottle contributors and collaborators on
this work and so this involves many
stakeholders in the community
and I'd also like to thank the
organizers again for the opportunity to
present this talk
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
about this work